the ESCOs history features some of the
most scandalous and quite frankly
hilarious moments across the gaming
world and this is a tribute to some of
the game's most ridiculous shocking and
intriguing paths boost my sir
it needs a now this train is considered
one of the biggest controversies at the
time fnatic infamous overpass boots is
still debated to this day whether you
think the boost was an amazing play that
was engineered by the great csgo minds
as fanatic or whether you think the
boost was completely illegal and
unnecessary you have to admit it made
for a memorable manageress pronax being
a genius alum 1303 after the first 15
rounds fnatic finally made their
three-man booth works as olofmeister
secured to push Hills on the
unsuspecting ldl-c fnatic would continue
to use and abuse the boost round after
round for the rest of the game and it
would eventually win them that map over
ldl-c the big issue with this booth was
actually that when using the boost some
textures would become invisible and that
was what was against tournament rules
they realized by giving from social
media that there is a texture bug so a
texture transparency from the box where
you can see almost down to the TSP you
can see what's called tunnel and in the
rules that is not allowed after a series
of back-and-forth between the teams and
the admins it was eventually ruled that
the entire map would be replayed after
the final decision however fnatic
forfeited that match and ldl-c would go
on to win their first major championship
chicken a lot of
although it's impossible to know exactly
when this Lobby Raider first appeared in
the private lobbies of professional csgo
players and tournaments around the world
what we do know is the incredible amount
of craze this radar generated across the
csgo community appearing in the private
lobbies of even valve sponsored events
such as ESL one Katowice 2015 and ESL
one cologne 2015 this Raider gained
notoriety within the community at a
rapid pace
chicken in the lobby you really really
want to play yes a good reg as well as
you can see that he was able to play
this semifinal you know in no time this
chicken had a booming social media
following and so many fake accounts
imitating him that it would become
almost impossible to keep track of the
real one this Lobby Raider gained so
much popularity so fast
that he even held an AMA with almost 500
comments and over 1600 upvote there are
several theories about the identity of
this anonymous lobby Raider with the
most popular being that this is a
character creation of the youtuber
failure especially considering his video
contribution to the chicken craze but I
guess there's no real way to tell for
sure like all things however this
character / mean would eventually fade
into obscurity but will never forget
that time when no one was safe from the
chicken to friend efficiency valve
Christmas gift to the csgo community the
r8 update the RA update was at the time
probably the most game breaking update
in the history of csgo not only was the
RA the most powerful pistol on release
it was hands down the most powerful gun
in the game although there were so many
things wrong about the r8 on release the
damage model was hands-down the most
broken the gun had an extremely high
base damage of 115 which meant you could
kill an enemy with one chocolate chance
yes but not only that it came with a
million bucks not only could you waste
ammo during free time if you could hold
both the left and right mouse buttons to
get the accuracy of a cannon of one but
the speed of a mouse - Shawn not only
that players could defuse the bomb and
right-click opponents at the exact same
time
needless
with outrage and tournament organizers
such as ESL refused to play on the new
update what the entire wrath of the
community had its doors valve nerfed the
re in a blog post entitled damage
control the nurse are significant enough
that less and less players began using
the r8 over time and although the r8 has
hardly ever used now there was a point
in time when the r8 outdid every other
gun these are the people that hold by my
face of me and unbanned
the people that made this the infamous
Rayna bug aka the birdies in December of
2014 train was reintroduced the csgo and
it came with a complete facelift this
was significant because it was the first
time in the game's history where a map
that was already in the game would
receive a complete overall signal II
more of that to come in the future
building the map from the ground up the
new de train was stunningly beautiful
but valve included a critical mistake it
would only take a couple of hours before
the community would learn of the birds
with all the changes that BAU had made
to the map a new addition was a spawning
of pigeons every couple of rounds down
by ivy the big issue was that these
pigeons had hit boxes that players could
use to jump that hopper and then enter
the map with the game breaking part of
the bug was that if used properly it
would allow clear visions down into the
a long sight to the player outside of
the map giving them an extremely unfair
advantage the bird beast was not
long-lived however as valve quickly got
rid of the bug and set up this mural in
memory of this hilarious moment
[Music]
Gaming Paradise I cannot believe that
managed to happen considered the worst
tournament ever held in the history of
csgo 2015's gaming paradise was anything
but to start things off the tournament
self began with a 12 hour delay in which
the tournament organizers explained the
delay was due to a road driver who
allegedly went missing with the
computers needed to run the tournament
replacement computers were eventually
brought in but they apparently were not
up to par and would drop frames and net
less than 100 frames per second in smoke
it gets worse police eventually arrived
at the players hotels and confiscated
their passports because as it turns out
the organisers had not paid those hotel
rooms the passports were later returned
to the players once the police were able
to confirm that the rooms were in fact
booked by the organizers and not the
players or community very very bad for
the mossad of this table the story
continues with the tournament organisers
eventually drafting up a new contract
that stated that the players would be
receiving their prize money by
completing their games but to no one's
surprise teach you who acquired the
kinguin lineup that won the tournament
released a statement later that year
which made it clear that the team was
not to receive any of the money that
they were promised a fittingly
horrendous end to a terrible tournament
congratulations with the bull the
gambling scandal and we found this new
site called csgo whatta for better or
worse csgo and again we market has been
in an intricate love affair since skins
were first released in the arms deal
update back in 2013
many would even say that weapon skins
are the reason why the game is so
popular although it can be said that the
gambling scandals first began with
former csgo player and now popular
streamer will have enroll as fat versus
csgo time law gambling scandals actually
really exploded when a youtuber by the
name of honour the call made of video
providing evidence that popular Call of
Duty youtubers tmartn and Pro syndicate
have promoted and gambled on csgo lotto
without disclosing the fact that they
were owners of that website through this
story several other notable streamers
and
personalities were dragged into the
forefront and the community began to
seriously consider the legitimacy and
morality of such websites
baozi response came in july when it
released an announcement stating that
they had no business relationships with
any of the gambling websites and that it
would send out notices to cease
operation val follow-through shortly
after with said letter and the letter
requested the immediate cease and desist
of a long list of popular gambling
websites such as csgo lotto yes go wild
guess gold diamonds and most notably
csgo lounge the gambling crackdown had
some stating that this was the end of
csgo competitive scene and viewership
but the csgo community held strong and
were able to set new viewership records
during the eleague major gentlemen
you'll made your Champions S tronic
the cloud9 Admiral scandal I don't even
care we're all on adderall like a [ __ ]
like csgo doe B scandal exploded mid
2015 when former cloud nine members
tempest admitted that she and the entire
c9 lineup at ESL one Katowice were on
adderall these remarks sparked a world
of controversy about the use of drugs in
eSports and ESL responded quickly
teaming up with the na da to run their
first anti PE d drug test for
ESL one cologne of that year when
cologne ended ESL released an article
detailing the immense success of the
event along with knew that the random PE
d testing held during the event came
back negative
successfully putting an end to the
biggest drug scandal in csgo history
[Music]
whole player back bans and the ensuing
which on Wow
near the end of 2014 a German pro player
SMN was first caught cheating through
the ESEA client valve and ESEA then
quickly work together to help update the
valve anti-cheat system and it was able
to detect and ban SMN of team alternate
access of Epsilon and most notably
Tiny's very own Cali music you want high
specials and need something special from
aged guys is a world under Callie soon
after the back man came clean stating
that he had in fact he's the chief where
we following his back man came and
extreme which one I know that a couple
of my teammates are convinced that
anything that she the man most affected
by this witch hunt was Russia of fnatic
at several venues accusing the fleet of
cheating seemed more and more popular
over the Internet Russia defended his
stance stating that she had never
cheated and that he will never cheat
explaining that his unique playstyle and
tendency to lift his mouth a lot more
than other pros as some of the
explanations for the community suspicion
although the wind child would die down
eventually at time past speculations and
suspicions of Pro flesh-eating they'll
continue to this daily my wife knows
time again aggression Palacios finds
maniac cruises welcome we'll leave in a
flash the infamous ibuypower throw can
they line up for him what is he doing
why did he have such pain this link that
would change the lines of all the
members involved the iBUYPOWER
match-fixing scandal is probably the
biggest eSports scandal of all time on
August 20th of 2014 two North American
teams ibuypower
and net kogai's calm were set to face
off in an online match for the fifth
season of Cee Lo's professional league
ibuypower were heavily favored in this
matchup but were blown out 4 to 16 when
the match ended there was some
speculation that the match was thrown by
ibuypower but it was quickly brushed
aside as just rumors the story then
later resurfaced when veteran East
sports journalist Richard Lewis brought
to light new evidence in January of 2000
fifteen the new evidence provided by
Richard Lewis was incriminating text
messages by Derrick be born born to its
former girlfriend the text explicitly
said that quote they really did throw
that match and I bet for them on
alternate accounts and clothes the rest
is as they say history as well put their
foot down on the people involved through
a blog post entitled integrity and fair
play in January of 2015 although at the
time the bands were indefinite valve in
their 2016 blog post entitled a
follow-up on integrity and fair play
confirmed that the bands would be in
fact permanent this is just really
surprising the Hat band what we got here
is a shoe it's because one of the
players of the mortals actually wasn't
worthy she has said looking at the topic
as a whole we have to trace it back to
Canada's own northern arena where I am
T's Henny was found not wearing his
headphones for the first two rounds of
their final map against ground nine this
event sparked a slew of controversy
around the importance of headgear
regulation and competitive play fast
forward about a month or so and sean
gares tweets out the following tweed
quote there needs to be rules on hazard
events without boots you should never be
able to see a player's here and close
this tweet stirred up a relevant
conversation about whether hats or
headgear in some way reduce the
effectiveness of noise canceling
headphones on the players head although
no firm conclusion could be made about
whether headgear was in fact obtrusive
to the noise canceling headphones or
whether pro players could use that to an
advantage the fact that the topic itself
was generating unnecessary controversy
around fair play became an issue the
response was Swift at the ESL made an
official rule ahead of its pro league
finals that headgear such as these would
not be allowed to be worn this trend
continued on to the recent new league
major qualifiers and even the e league
major itself and it will most likely
continue on for the foreseeable future
and that's the list please let us know
in the comments below if you felt like
we might have missed anything
make sure to hit that like button and
subscribe for more csgo content thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button